you
[Music]
good morning first of all think thank
you organization from having me here
it's really exciting exciting to stand
on stage I I haven't done a talk in
about a year and a half I joined date a
dog about a half year ago so might be a
little rusty so bear with me it's also a
little early so I'm about to be which
touch a little bit of hard to announce
for some people but you can butcher my
name later if you want to I'm an
engineering director at at at data dog
and mostly focused on on data
engineering so we do this talk and I've
kind of gonna speak for all of you when
when doing this talk by asking a few
questions that you might want to ask so
so laughter what are you going to talk
about in the next 40 minutes just have
my coffee breakfast dying to listen to
your talk so tell me tell me more so
what I'm going to talk about is is how I
feel data engineering teams over the
years will talk a little bit about they
gender engineering itself some common
patterns that there are of that I've
seen while building these teams I'll
want to talk a little bit about
horizontal and vertical teams and
explain what that is and how do how to
get high-performing team so this talk is
not going to be technical there are lots
of technical technical talks this this
conference but figured might be fun to
talk a little bit about something else
so right rods are nice to meet you but
before you start like who are you and
why you talk to us well Who am I so I'm
about to be engineering director at day
dog and as Pete mentioned formally
engineering director at Spotify I'm
Dutch I live in Brooklyn New York
until next week so great we're here to
talk about about data not about where
you're moving but still like probably a
few of you wonder where I'm actually
going so from next week I'll be living
in in
New Orleans Louisiana which is like
probably one of my favorite cities in
the world
I'm actually very very blessed to be
able to to move there it's the Internet
age data dog lets me work remotely
travel back and forth to New York and to
and to Paris Winston well we have Mardi
Gras which is pretty awesome alright
let's let's go to business you've been
at a few I've been a few companies
before what have you that they've gone
through hyper growth what did that
really mean
so yeah Spotify went through hyper
growth we had when I started in 2011
there were 250 people global engineering
team was about 70 when I left there were
5,500 people so in and I left in 2018 so
over the course of 7 years we had gone
from 250 to 5500 kind of a fast growth
data dog has been growing like doubled
every year in in in terms of employees
we're currently at about 1,500 people so
that's that's what hyper growth means to
me but Walter apart from employee growth
did you have any
scalability challenges like yeah scale
skill is a big big challenge so if you
look at data they dog David owns a
company that focuses on observability as
a service and we ingest metrics traces
and logs from our from our customers we
are in multiple clouds and we do
billions of points a day and that we
ingest from from from all of our form of
our customers we process that we
visualize that we create alerts we
trigger things so that's that's a pretty
massive scale at the moment
Spotify had the same thing some music
streaming servers probably most of you
know no Spotify most of the data that we
collected was about playback so you'd
play a song we'd record what you were
playing by which artist and do all sorts
of cool stuff with that apart from
reporting and making sure that artists
get paid we would do recommendations
yeah all sorts of product features we
hundreds of millions of plays a day
and hundreds of millions of active users
on a monthly basis so that to me was
scale and obviously there are companies
that are bigger that do large scale but
still there's there's quite a lot of
there were a lot of lot of challenges in
that but today we're we're here to talk
about data engineering so might here you
think so out there you did a bunch of
data engineering tell me tell me about
about that what did you do I first
wanted to talk about the definition of
data engineering because there seems to
be a bunch of there seems to be a bunch
of definitions out there I just googled
data engineering and definition and
these were the first three hits that I
got so looking at a blog post on tech
target it defines data engineering data
engineer is a worker who whose primary
job responsibilities involved repairing
data for analytical or operational or
the uses O'Reilly mentions built and
maintained organizational data pipeline
systems clean and wrangled data I like
that I like that term into a usable
state and then data camp had ensure
clean reliable and performative access
to data and databases I want to throw in
my own definition here because one of
the things that I really missed this
sort of the the scale when we talk about
data data engineering a data dog we're
talking about the large volumes of data
it's often batch not not per se but it's
really the volume that matters in this
case which I'll talk later about it it
requires different skills so data
engineering takes care of storing and
processing large volumes of data coming
from different sources and making it
available for downstream applications so
it could be machine learning analytics
we could use it in in product features
etc the doctor these data engineering
these data engineers they process data
and such but who runs those systems that
that they use so at de dog and we did
the same thing at Spotify we made a
a differentiation between data
engineering and data infrastructure
engineering so I want to throw in
another definition here to me data
infrastructure engineering that builds
maintains and operates the systems that
enable data and engineers to do their
work so if you look at the different
skills required on one hand we have data
engineering that those are people that
write spark MapReduce Apache beam
dataflow pipelines etc the skills that
are required are definitely
understanding sort of data concepts how
to wrangle that data like sorting
grouping filtering things like that
aggregating data you see that often
people who work as data engineers have
to have an understanding of the domain
that they're working with so for example
a data dog the data engineering team is
highly specialized in understanding how
metrics work how do you aggregate
metrics in both space and time for
example how do you optimize optimize
these processes but really specific to
the domain at Spotify used to work with
teams that are that were specialized in
the domain of creators so the record
labels and artists they knew everything
about that domain or being able to
prepare data for further analysis or
machine learning etc and data engineers
often have to understand the scalability
of data like how do you say that you go
10x in volume how do we deal with that
how do we optimize our pipelines to be
able to run this this stuff on the other
hand we have data infrastructure
engineering these people the people on
those teams they operate the processing
systems they have an understanding of
things like yarn may sauce HDFS like
Hadoop isn't as an ecosystem these
people often writes tools to make life
easier for data engineers so data dog we
use a system called mortar the mortar
enables us to to schedule spark jobs
mostly spark jobs it uses Luigi under
the hood which is a
a dependency resolution an orchestration
system that I actually wrote together
with my team it's modified back in a day
so these teams they they build not they
don't only maintain and operate the
systems that allow us to run these data
jobs but also write a bunch of software
and they won't and they understand the
scalability of systems they obviously
have to think about what it means if the
volume of data gets like ten times as
large but they don't have to have that
domain knowledge they really have to
understand systems so you often see when
when hiring hiring teams that on one
hand data engineering is I would say a
skill that hasn't been taught for for
that long so you have people coming out
of school nowadays understanding more
about like big data processing but it's
it's kind of a relatively new new field
well in data infrastructure engineering
there's more overlap with with sort of
regular back in engineering and
distributed systems but of course
there's overlap so and I'll get into
that more but there is overlap still yet
people in the data engineering it did
infrastructure engineering side have to
understand more of like what the data
means then it's a typical back-end
engineer so here you think butter you've
been at a few companies there any common
common patterns that you've observed
while like building these teams and yes
obviously so what I've seen is that you
could like the evolution of of data
engineering at the companies that I've
been at follows follow sort of a common
common path big data starts small often
so there is some interesting data
somewhere at a data dog obviously this
is data that comes from our customers at
Spotify that was usage data from our
users Spotify this data was already used
for creating reports that went to record
labels and based on that artists would
would get paid that was part of the
business model a data dog that data
comes in because we actually have to
realize that our customers have to be
able to query it I have to do and do
things but very early on in the stage of
these companies that data is already
there what I've seen is that it often
starts so that the whole big data
journey starts with a small team and
that one small team does a lot with with
with the data they do multiple things
with it and at the same time this team
operates the infrastructure that is
there does data engineering and often
performs analytics so those are the only
people that do that now once things grow
and the data the value of big data
becomes apparent the small team tends to
be a bottleneck so what happens is that
that small team starts splitting up into
analytics data engineering data
infrastructure engineering sometimes
sometimes other other teams even when
you see like that that that growing
let's modify we went from a small we
call the business intelligence back in a
day business intelligence team that did
everything to analytics infrastructure
which later became data infrastructure
and analytics team etc a data dog we're
sort of at that point we had a team a
1:1 team that did both data engineering
and data infrastructure today we have we
have two teams probably by the end of
the year we have three or four teams
more focused on on different aspects of
data processing data engineering and
then so do the last step is that Big
Data becomes part of day-to-day so data
engineering rather than being a central
team doing stuff data engineering
becomes more of a competence so every
every part of the business will will
eventually have data engineers that like
prepare data that work with with day to
day and day out because every domain
starts starts needing that what we
started Spotify was that the creator
side of the house had data engineers
really specifically focused on artists
and labels we had data engineers for
machine learning preparing data for me
learning we had data engineers that
would do product analysis or worked on
the on the product side and prepare data
for analytics so if you look at data
dogs evolution I kind of alluded to that
already there was a single team that
focused on analytics and data
engineering and infrastructure and
single team split it into into sort of
data engineering and data infrastructure
these are currently the teams that are
in my in my group and currently we have
that data infrastructure team we have a
data engineering team for historical
metrics what happens at data dogs that
we ingest we ingest data from or we get
data from our customers that goes into
live systems for querying but that data
only stays there for about 17 hours
because storing data in live systems and
in memories is really really expensive
and on on SSDs for fast access the use
cases change after like they say 17
hours from sort of immediate access to
data to like longer-term graphing for
example and longer-term queries so what
we do at the same time is the data gets
processed by by spark jobs we run a
bunch of ETL on that and do do pre
aggregations or aggregations on the data
and make it available to our query
system our very smart query system is
then able to load data from the from the
the live systems and from the historical
files that we produce and can give
results back to to our customers so this
is all happen seamlessly but underwater
there so there's a bunch of spark jobs
that are running so that's what what
this team does we have an internal
analytics group they do all sorts of
cool cool analysis on the data that we
have we have a team that's called
revenue engineering that basically looks
at usage and and eventually builds our
customers based on that usage and then
we have data science using using the
data as well compare that to to Spotify
is evolution same thing we started off
with with a team focused on analytics
data engineering and
an infrastructure that was a team that I
joined back in back in 2011 there was
really three engineers and three
analysts and we pretty much did
everything we ran Hadoop we created data
pipelines back in the day this was a
Python MapReduce don't ever do that we I
had at least three Excel sheets open on
my desktop every day to help out with
with some analytics but then as I
mentioned that became a bottleneck that
team because there was there was so much
there were so many questions from all
over the business started off with
analytical questions but more and more
people wanted to wanted to have product
features we had top lists for example
and that meant that that led to to
splitting this team up in into sort of
analytics and data infrastructure and
within data infrastructure we even did a
lot of data data engineering as well
currently at Spotify there's a data
infrastructure organization when I left
a year and a half ago there was about 50
people I think there they might be a
little bit bigger right now and data
engineering is a competence there isn't
a single like centralized data
engineering team anymore but that
happens all over the place
analytics has become a competence so
before so annelids was a was a single
team for for quite a while but also that
became became a bottleneck so product
analytics is very different than
marketing analytics then financial
analytics etc so you saw these like
people specializing and then moving into
these parts of the business and then
data science is a competence as well
there so we have data scientists all
over the place because you have data
scientists focusing on recommendations
you have data science is focusing on
stuff for artists etc and I hear you
think about there when when data
engineering becomes a competence then
that can be found in many teams and how
do we ensure that knowledge is is shared
and I think this is one of the bigger
problems that I've seen organizationally
how do you keep people together and feel
that they belong to sort of a group of
data engineers or data science or or
analytics and while they're working on
different things how do you make sure
that everybody uses the same tools that
everybody uses the same the same
processes so there are two things that
I've done in the past one is called
what's called a data engineering guild
this is spot if I had some interesting
organizational structures and spot if I
had interesting organizational lingo I
don't know how many of you are to have
seen some of some of Spotify little
videos about how they are organized but
it's part of had a matrix organization
which meant that management and delivery
was was separated
we had squads and chapters where people
were working on which also caused the
cause the problem of people had to
belong together or had to become had to
come together to share knowledge and the
organizational structure that they that
they invented was called the guild and
within a guild no actual work happened
but people would come together to share
share knowledge about how they would
work what kind of tools they would use
and even sometimes set standards a data
dog the same thing happens so we have
data engineers in revenue engineering we
have it in team data engineering metrics
we have it in in analytics etc and twice
a week engineers come together and talk
about about stuff that either needs to
be done or new technologies that have
emerged new new ways of working new
paradigms are being discussed a David
ugh there's a bit more focus on the
guild actually doing things together
which I kind of like it's fun get to
work with people from from different
sides of the different side of the
company so we work on deprecating like
old old libraries for example in our
case we we have to have to move from
Python to to Python 3 because Python 3
Python 2 is being deprecated that's a
nice thing to work on with the guild
because everybody
asked to do this so you have people from
that guild driving that in different in
different teams but it's a kind of a
informal group and it's very self self
organized a second thing that I did at
Spotify was started data University this
is a curriculum that was focused on on
teaching data engineering skills and it
was used for onboarding but also for
training engineers in sort of the art of
of data engineering she had this was
mostly back in engineers I would say but
also a few front end people here and
there that were interested in data
engineering so that guy I would just
want to add this to my my toolbox to my
skill set and so we look me in and a few
colleagues wrote a curriculum ran that
about every quarter started off with ten
ten people in a room and after about a
year this this became fairly large with
like 50 or 60 people taking those taking
a course for a week
going from like how do you operate not
super in-depth but like what does what
does MapReduce mean for example how do
we because it's kind of still the
foundation for many of those many of
those frameworks out there too like how
do you get your data from one point to
another point how do you process data
how do you expose that how do you make
it available for downstream teams for
downstream systems etc so that was a I
think was a great tool because that
really sort of accelerated data
engineering as a competence throughout
these three systems and people don't
have to be formally trained whatever
that means in in in data engineering so
here you think right so I need a bunch
of teams how do you then decide how to
divide my engineers give me any tips so
if you split teams and obviously you
need to split them across across
something so I'd like to talk a little
bit about horizontal versus vertical
teams and I use this a lot when thinking
about team structures and because there
are so many dimensions that you can
slice and dice a team around when you're
going through through a split when teams
become too big and you need to need to
split them
so what I mean with horizontal and
vertical is that to me vertical teams
have a narrow focus on often one group
of constituents and I have a little
example later or like a single domain so
for example in data dog we have
historical metrics that say that's a
pretty specific domain because data dog
we have metrics APM and logs as sort of
the three pillars of our product so
historical the metrics is is one sort of
vertical it's it's it's a narrow narrow
thing revenue engineering is a narrow
vertical because it it is like being
able to build our customers that's
really the use case and Spotify we had
recommendations that was a vertical is
our recommendations for our customers is
not a very broad broad spectrum of
things then we have horizontal teams and
they have a wide focus on often just
providing data to many other downstream
downstream teams so they don't really
care about the domain any particular
domain it's really making sure that
other teams are are able to use the data
they have access to data in a way that
works for them and infrastructure by
definition is is horizontal so you have
it supports the rest of your teams so as
an example here you can see that so
analytics is often sort of a horizontal
actually analytics is can be both
horizontal and vertical depending on how
your organization works but say product
analytics would be would be a horizontal
sorry a vertical vertical team or part
of the organization revenue is his
vertical metrics is vertical for for
data dog machine learning data science
can be vertical and then when it comes
to horizontal we can often have a tee
you can have a team that works on what I
like to call foundational data this is
data that can be used by all these these
other teams and again that team
organization part of the organization
doesn't really care about the but
the domain of that data at Spotify we
had a organization that I was part of at
the end of my my stint there it was
called just data which is kind of cool
name and we made sure that the data that
really mattered for the business so we
call the business critical data was was
owned by by that team but that business
critical data was used for finance it
was used for ads it was used for for ML
etc and then underneath all of that that
is supported by data infrastructure data
infrastructure make sure that these
teams can can do whatever they need to
do so here you think see router but now
I have all these teams being autonomous
and all they can do whatever they need
to do but they're building the same
thing over and over again like this team
uses this framework that team uses that
framework team a builds builds a
scheduler Team B builds schedule any any
thoughts about that yes I do because
this is where infrastructure comes comes
into play this is like the part where
infrastructure should shine and how I
tend to look at infrastructure in
general try to sort of Express that here
in this in this diagram is where if you
look at how data often flows comes in
through some front end a data dog that's
most of most of the data comes in
through agents that are installed in on
hosts but it could be for other things
that's modified this was through Spotify
clients and your mobile and your desktop
web player etc today that comes in
through the front end then often goes to
to back-end service back-end stuff
happens there then that ends up in
something that does data I tried to tend
to avoid the term data Lake but that's
often where people refer to so that's
where data data pipelines happen and
then that data is often used for
analytics and data science and you could
even in this I guess I forgot that but
you could even draw a an arrow back to
either back end or front end because
that data can be used in a product but
to be able to for all these teams to
move move fast and focus on what they
actually need to do you have to have
great infrastructure so
what we often see what I've often seen
is that on the client there's client
infrastructure some team helps client
teams build their there are things they
help out with frameworks they set what
frameworks are used or they bless
frameworks to be used they make sure
that say mobile clients can be built
that their CI CD for those kind of
things the same on the backend
infrastructure side companies that I've
seen move fast often have have have like
a standardized back-end in place so they
use a specific technology to to build
deploy and run back-end services at
Spotify we used a lot of Java in the
backend they had a system called
Apollo that you would if you would start
an Apollo project you will get
monitoring and alerting and service
service discovery service connections
for free and that that like cause people
like made people to use that backend
technology rather than like deploying
their own stuff at data dock we pretty
much standardized on go for for our
back-end applications there's a lot of
infrastructure and tooling around making
sure that you can build and deploy your
go go projects and then data
infrastructure the same thing so it
Spotify we standardized on Luigi for a
while
data dog we do a very similar thing some
companies go for airflow but yeah it's
really making sure that everybody kind
of uses the same thing and these teams
don't have to do everything over and
over again and the same goes for data
science and and and analytics although I
would say on the analytics side it's a
little different or a little harder
because there's there's a whole bunch of
tools that each have their own their own
value so alright router so grandma org
split my team's hired the right folks
now how do they make sure that they that
they perform so we'll have to talk a
little bit about sort of high-performing
teams and what I've seen in the past
what works to make make teams
high-performing I really subscribe to
this
autonomy mastery and purpose autonomy is
like our desire to be self-directed and
it increases engagement over compliance
mastery is the urge to get better skills
and purpose is the desire to do
something that has meaning and is
important and if you make sure that
these teams that the people on these
teams should have subscribe to this I've
seen people like the teams that that
really embody this perform the best in
certain cases there's a sort of a
tendency to add a lot of process to two
two teams that can help definitely can
help but the essence is that if a team
or an individual feels that they can
make autonomous decisions if they master
what they do and you give them
challenges to to really do do what they
what they can do and you give them
purpose then things tend to tend to run
much much much smoother so some of you
might have might have seen this say like
that make sense I see you read drive by
by Daniel H pink which I did this is a
great book if you haven't haven't read
it would definitely recommend it but how
do I make my team's value autonomy
mastery and purpose you can just hand
them a book and say do this right so
what I've what I've seen it's hiring is
really really key a data dog we have a
very specialized we have a specialized
interview process for both data
engineering and data infra we make a
difference there we we ask different
questions don't sort of throw it all on
one one pile and have a similar
interview for everything for both day
dog and Spotify there was a great focus
on on skill but also on culture
unfortunately I've had to reject
candidates that didn't fit the culture
and and because cultural if you if you
over time encounter cultural issues and
like people just don't fit sort of what
you how you how you run run a company
then those those mistakes can can lead
to too
our issues if you have a technical
problem you can often solve it people
are a little a little bit more difficult
so that's why I like in both these
companies look a big focus on culture
and enthusiasm for the product that you
that you have is really really important
that's what really struck me starting a
data dog is that everybody is so
enthusiastic about what we do and the
product that we have we all use it on a
day to day basis so we dog food and the
pun is very much intended there we we
all use data dog on a day-to-day basis
which which is great because we also get
to help improve the product we find
issues with it and then we can we can
help out but make it make it better but
everybody's really really enthusiastic
about the product really enthusiastic
about where the company is going and
that really really helps when when
building teams so some of you are here
think all right man learn something
feeling the coffee can we can we wrap
this up let's wrap this up so just want
to hope that you walk out of this room
with with a few takeaways I think one
important thing for me at least having
gone through my journey working with
data engineering and data infrastructure
teams is that data engineering isn't
data infrastructure so think hopefully
think a little bit about that going
going forward teams and organizations
evolve and that's fine not having a plan
is sometimes okay just let it let things
happen and you'll end up in a but with a
little bit of thought you will end up in
a place that that works for you for me
the horizontal and vertical thinking has
helped a lot to be able to make
decisions on how do we split teams how
do we grow the organization where do we
invest things like that it's really
important to build solid infrastructure
make sure that your team's folk can
focus on what they are requested to do
and not doing things over and over again
and as I just mentioned like hiring is
hiring is key so lastly just wanted to
put a shameless plug in there most of
you might have seen us we're in the back
there we are hiring
so if you're looking for a fun fun
challenge with a lot of scale a lot of
data with cool people then please come
and come and see us we're doing some
demos there as well Raphael is doing an
amazing job there so come and see us at
our booth thank you so much if you have
any questions we'll take them that fit
so a lot of teams here are are smaller
than data dog and naturally the the
skills collapse probably sometimes and
even one person the data engineer the
data instruction engineer etc at what
scale like number of people in the team
do you think it starts to make sense to
think about splitting that's a really
good question
I tend to like they're on the side of
eight people is the max for a team after
eight people so we were actually in this
in this exact situation a data dog one
of the teams is about 12 people big and
our stand-ups in the morning used to
take five to ten minutes we did quick
quick updates they take 25 minutes to
two half an hour which means that it's
not only the amount of people in a room
but also the scope of the team grows and
you see that there are multiple I
wouldn't say camps because that that
sounds very sort of boxy but we see that
people check out because they haven't
worked on a specific part of what the
team does for a while and yeah they did
they don't really engage theirs they you
kind of lose that sense of belonging
with I would say more than eight or nine
people so I tend to say add about eight
people we need to we need to start
splitting as I said this team is now 12
or 13 people big which I was a little
late with with thinking about the split
but yeah hyper growth you know and what
about specifically between the data
engineering team and the data
infrastructure engineering team is there
a size there where you think it starts
to split apart those two functions not
really I think when when this team
splits the data engineering sort of data
engineering and infor was one team we
split that up the data engineering the
day in fur team was only three people we
started with three people while the rest
was like
six or seven people on the engineering
side so it doesn't always have to be a
50/50 split in this case there were
people that were more interested in
infrastructure than in data engineering
the need for data engineering was at
them at the time higher there were more
projects and then then on the
infrastructure side so yeah it doesn't
have to be a 50/50 great awesome things
hi thanks for tout and regarding
autonomy vertical and horizontal teams
so how do you handle situations where
someone wants to build new thing or use
new library but then you have the
horizontal teams regarding autonomy so
if an individual wants you use a
particular library or or a specific
vertical team that hey we think that now
we need to use this new thing and all
the tooling provided by horizontal teams
doesn't match so it's somebody on a on a
say vertical team what the vertical team
wants to use particular technology and
and and the horizontal team doesn't
doesn't support that is that yeah okay
yeah so I think that's fine if there is
an actual yet use case for that right if
there is if it's just because you know
we're actually we're normally using Java
but I'm more into Erlang and Erling is
better you get sort of these holy wars
then I think it's a bad idea to to
introduce introduced new technology and
introduce entropy in your in your
environment if it's for a good cause
because there's functionality that's
just not support it and I think that
team should really do that in some cases
it just stays very local to that team
because the only that that vertical team
has that has a need for that technology
in other cases other teams might take
that on and then through something like
a guild you might see that particular
thing spread I think it's a job of
horizontal teams to pick up on that and
said well there's five there are five
teams who are using this this thing this
should actually be more of a horizontal
function so we're taking this on as part
of our sort of internal product
portfolio or whatever you call it and
and start really supporting that for all
these teams and making sure that it
becomes more of a generic solution then
a very specific one for for each
team that yeah sort of snowflake have
different needs thanks hi I have a
question about another dimension of
division about data and transactional or
data again regarding the the
infrastructure engineers have to be
splitted the data a toaster engineers
and mechanics raster engineer or not is
a competence is the same competence same
kind of team same guild same chapter
because there are some speciality is
there is there is exist a big overlap
but also there are some specific things
that the data infrastructures do and I
can do a lot of thing yeah and I hear
yeah so the question is like is because
there's overlap between back-end and
data infrastructure like how does that
work is that that's kind of yeah ok so
yeah that's absolutely true like
especially in the beginning of these
teams you see that a lot of sort of
back-end engineers and tend to sort of
gravitate towards towards data
infrastructure as like hey you know like
I used to operate a Cassandra cluster I
know that type of stuff which is cool
you know you have it's a big Java system
now we have a doob for example let me
let me like do that type of stuff so you
see a lot of there's a lot of overlap
and there's a lot of like competence
that can be needed can be can be used
but yeah data infrastructure is far more
towards towards back in infrastructure
if you look at data dog for example our
back-end infrastructure is mostly go and
like data infrastructure it's a little
bit of a different thing because it's
it's most of the systems are JVM base we
use Scala a lot instead of instead of
ghost so there's there's less overlap
there in terms of sort of paradigms and
and thinking I guess it's it's similar
so you do see people transition from
back-end to to data infrastructure or
the other way around and that's fine
just use whatever whatever you whatever
you need I like and make sure that
people can
move but I personally think that
operating data infrastructure is a
little different than then backend often
because the stack is very different
thank you
one more question about competence
versus separate team as you said that
and Spotify is a data sense for instance
is more like competence and currently
you have separate teams I guess that you
you would like to split ins in between
the activities rather than having
different competence in the same team
but on my point of view having for
instance that wasn't competent they
would do two different things and watch
his knowledge
house sharing the knowledge between
co-workers in the same team what do you
think about that so I'm not sure if I
completely understand the question I
mean that having competence probably for
small teams is button separating the
team to different departments
it helps sharing zenovich yeah so I
think like so how I think about these
things that competence the competence
can be part of a team right actually
have so what we did at Spotify more so
than I think I dated out because the the
teams are formed far more homogenous
into the requirements of skill but it
Spotify we had teams that say we worked
on radio then you had in the radio team
there was front-end back-end data
science data engineering in in one team
together basically being able to to
build a feature from A to Z in other
cases you might have a team that's part
of a larger organization that is
specifically focused on say data science
and it really I would say like but being
able to do that being able to have
different organizational structures like
putting all competence in a team that's
part of an organized
station or having a single person in a
team performing or like building
building a particular feature is only
you can only do that if you see say data
science or data engineering as a
competence
[Music]